Ms,
this video is brought to you by
squarespace.
Whether you need a domain,
website or online store,
make it with squarespace.
A wise crack,
desperately needs a haircut.
Jared here,
so we just saw black panther and got to
say it's probably one of the better
marvel films and the element that
elevates it is something rarely seen in
the mcu,
a complex antagonist,
even the best marvel films feature
villains that fit the same generic
pattern,
try to take over the world for reasons
that are rarely more complex than they
are for Pinky and the brain.
Same thing we do every night,
pinky try to take over the world.
It's just what marvel villains do.
Eagle wants to take over the universe
because he's egotistical.
Hello,
wants to take over as guard so she can
then take over the nine realms and hydro
wants to take over the world because
they're literal Nazis,
but killmonger is different.
He's got compelling and relatable
reasons,
motivating his attempt to global
conquests.
So much so that we found ourselves
asking,
is killmonger the best superhero villain
since the joker?
Welcome to this wise crack quick take on
marbles.
Black Panther,
and as always,
spoilers ahead,
so what motivates,
kill longer,
simply put,
he's seeking retribution for the
injustices leveled against people of
African descent by Western countries.
This includes the obvious like slavery
and segregation,
but also other wrongs,
including redlining in which unfair
government loan policies for blacks to
live in ghettos and racial profiling by
police in which increased patrolling and
impoverished black neighborhoods
contributes to the mass incarceration of
black men in America apply to which
current Black Panther writer,
Tanahashi coats often writes about,
and by the way,
if you're interested in hearing more
about how coats and other Afro
pessimistic views are being expressed in
pop culture,
I recommend listening to the get out
episode of our movie podcast.
Show me the meaning anyway.
Though these injustices are only
obliquely alluded to in the film,
including a humorous bit with sheree
calling Bilbo a colonizer.
They formed the obvious subtext.
Every time killmonger mentions the
plight of blacks living outside of
Wakanda apply that will conduct,
could presumably fix,
and this leads to one of the film
central questions should Macondo,
do more to address the inequities of the
outside world initially that will
condoms want to maintain their isolation
is politics and killmonger wants to
conquer the oppressors,
thereby colonizing the old colonial
powers.
This juxtaposition of isolationism
versus colonialism is one of several
false dichotomies introduced by
killmonger that characterize the
thematic structure of Black Panther.
So what do I mean by false dichotomy
throughout the film?
Killmonger prompts a number of binaries
such as isolationism versus colonialism
or traditionalism versus progress,
but as the film ultimately reveals,
there's no reason to look at these
issues as a choice between two
absolutes.
There's usually a third way,
a middle path between two extremes or
what aristotle called the golden mean,
and this golden mean defines to Challas
character arc to Cholla grows when he
learns to avoid the simplistic solutions
at the far ends of the spectrum.
So let's explore these dichotomies.
The first,
it's a question of how to construct a
group identity,
national identity versus racial
identity.
The people of will conda are extremely
nationalistic.
They view the world is divided into two
groups,
will competence and everybody else.
This leads to a Wakanda first attitude
among many citizens.
They've built walls,
refused refugees,
reject trade and offer no foreign aid
all in the name of protecting Wakanda
because they value the lives of those
who share the same heritage and culture
as themselves,
but killmonger having grown up in
America has developed a strong sense of
racial identity for him because we'll
condoms have the same skin color as
blacks and the rest of the world.
Well condoms should see themselves as
part of a global black community.
Among the first thing he says when he
takes the throne is something like all
around the world,
people that look like us are suffering
in his speech at the United Nations,
at the end of the film to Cholla rejects
both the Wakandans nationalism and kill
mongers ethnicity and instead accepts
the middle road offered by humanism.
He specifically states that all of
humanity is one tribe.
It's a surprisingly colorblind message,
but a welcome one.
The second false dichotomy is
traditionalism versus progress.
For all its technological advancements.
Will conduct is an extremely traditional
society,
regularly engaging in ancient rituals
such as the combat for the crown or the
ingesting of the heart shaped herb for
killmonger progress requires getting rid
of traditions such as when he destroys
the garden of heart shaped herbs and
refuses to continue the ceremonial
combat with the cello.
One could even say his philosophy echoes
that of Kylo Ren.
The middle ground is keeping what
traditions he can,
but rejecting what wasn't working
specifically,
what condos,
isolation and its hostility with the
Jabari.
The film's final dichotomy is the
aforementioned isolationism versus
colonialism.
Most Wakandans believe continuing their
centuries old tradition of isolationism
to be the most prudent path to
maintaining peace,
including initially to Cholla.
Killmonger on the other hand,
subscribes to a theory mentioned
frequently in the film that the world is
getting smaller and you're either the
conquered or the conquerors killmonger
solution that will condoms should take
part in the same harmful colonialism
that's afflicted.
Black individuals.
For centuries,
killmonger seeks to repay historic
injustices,
tit for tat by arming oppress black
communities around the world with
advanced weaponry and inciting race
riots and radical revolution killmonger.
His political philosophy is reminiscent
of the French revolution,
which was fueled by fantasies of the
oppressed,
exacting revenge upon their oppressors.
Killmonger is desire for vengeance is so
impassioned,
but he seems to give no thought to
governing after destroying Western
society.
I like his construction of color and
race.
This too is a result of his American
upbringing.
Killmonger story is like that of many
African Americans,
for whom military service was the only
viable path out of poverty,
and it was the American military which
trained him in the art of regime,
change his time in the special forces
having been spent overseeing various
coups and conquests in the Middle East.
Not only does this result in him being
more interested in revolution than
actual rule,
it's also darkly ironic.
He wants to colonize the so called
colonizers because that's what the
colonizers taught him to do.
This is part of what makes killmonger
such a sympathetic villain,
and yes,
he is a villain.
Unlike the Challah,
he doesn't look for the golden mean,
he's an extremist in both his beliefs
and violent methodologies,
but this extremism is painted as a
direct result of Western society
grappling with it's messy.
Past killmonger is a dark reflection of
the sins of our forefathers justice.
He blamed for the actions of his father
to Chaka.
He blames everyone else for their
ancestors actions as well,
but to Cholla rejects this when he says
to them [inaudible],
that he is not responsible for past what
condon,
kings mistreatment of the Jabari people
and while to Cholla doesn't deny the
wrongdoings of westerners past.
He acts without animosity toward their
present,
a descendants.
It's this optimism which allows to
challah to chart a course between the
extremes of isolationism and conquest by
the films and to Challah is persuaded by
killmonger that there is a need for
Wakanda to provide global aid and
assistance just without the violent
conquest.
The movie closes with the Child Building
and outreach center in Oakland to help
the people that kill monger was fighting
for,
and that's what makes killmonger is such
a phenomenal villain.
Whereas most bad guys represent a clear
cut,
evil that must be unilaterally defeated.
Killmonger is disposition is one that
must be adopted.
Killmonger doesn't just challenge our
protagonists,
he guides them and provides them with
the insight team needs to become a truly
great king in the face of very divisive
issues.
The child is able to synthesize these
solutions in a way that works best for
Wakanda and the world.
It's like Afro Futuristic,
Hagle.
Hope you guys enjoyed the movie as much
as we did and as always,
thanks for watching.
Peace.
Thanks for watching guys,
and as everybody knows,
to Challah and never freezes and neither
should your website go to squarespace to
design your next website and use the
offer code quick take to get 10 percent
off your first purchase of a website or
domain today.
Squarespace makes it easy to make
beautiful websites from scratch with
zero coding knowledge.
It's so simple to create a home for your
project or business with squarespace's
all in one platform.
Even my dog would.
He has his own website.
Now you,
he's on the path to becoming a celebrity
dog,
and look,
I'm not going to let my lack of coding
ability stand in his way.
You can check it out at wisecrack.
Would e.squarespace.com.
I recommend it.
It took less than an hour to build and
with squarespace's designer templates,
award winning 24 slash seven customer
support,
easy domain transfer and online
inventory management.
Even you can become a famous dog
celebrity in no time.
For a free trial,
head on over to squarespace.com/quick
takes.
You'll also save 10 percent off your
first purchase of a website or domain.
If you use the Promo Code quicktakes.
As always,
be sure to subscribe and ring that Bell
Catchall next time.
Peace.